[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
ein eigenwilliges zwillingsduo und ihr
neuer betörender spielfilm
herr kulturschaffende die sich mit ihren
eigenen mitteln politisch engagieren und
große musik die aller erste probe für
eine außergewöhnliche uraufführung
[Musik]
wir kommen hat sein produkt ja heute
machen wir station im neuen stadtcasino
basel und zwar wird hier ein ganz
unerhörtes stück musik uraufgeführt eine
mischung zwischen klassik und folklore
und diese folkloristisch stand das wenn
schweizer wie auch aus den indischen
bergen da bin ich mal gespannt wie das
klingt
[Musik]
fürs erste aber beschäftigen wir uns mit
der kraft des widerstandes und ich meine
in diesem fall den subversiven
widerstand ein beispiel aus deutschland
dort wollten kultur schaffen der die
korona politik ironisch kommentieren und
forderten den lockt ein für immer unter
dem hashtag alles dicht machen worauf
andere fragten seid ihr noch ganz dicht
ja so ist das mit ironie und aktionismus
aber es kann auch gelingen
[Musik]
dieses video wendet sich direkt an die
mitarbeitenden von bayern tag
du hast bei der entwicklung des biontech
impfstoffs mitgeholfen
dank deiner arbeit werden wir die korona
krise meistern und weitere todesopfer
vermeiden was nach einem heroischen
werbevideo aussieht ist in wirklichkeit
ein aufruf an wissenschaftlerinnen die
geheimen formel zu veröffentlichen damit
auch die ärmeren länder des globalen
südens impfstoff produzieren können
der patentschutz verhindert die
weltweite produktion du hast es in der
hand liege jetzt die herstellungs-
anleitung für den bond impfstoff
[Musik]
ist das fake ein aufruf zu zivilem
ungehorsam
es ist eine aktion des künstler innen
kollektivs peng einem explosiven gemisch
aus aktivismus hecking und kunst so ihre
selbstbeschreibung mitbegründer sean
peters schlüpft bei vielen aktionen in
verschiedene rollen die bei dieser
vierten pressekonferenz des
energiekonzerns vattenfall
heute kann es war deren pressesprecher
in seinem buch wenn die hoffnung stirbt
geht es trotzdem weiter berichtet er aus
dem kreativ labor einer protestkultur
des anklagen sessions und entlarven
2014 verlieren sie den waffen konzern
thyssenkrupp marine systems eine nicht
existenten friedenspreis was der
konzernvertreter hier mit dieser hand
markiert gar nicht lustig fand jeder
machen ist dass wir die menschen auf
eine theaterbühne stellen und da den
vorhang auf machen und dann können die
leute schauen ja und plötzlich sind die
von waffen konzernunternehmen politiker
in oder so sind plötzlich selber
schauspielerin und fragen sich hoch
würde ich das überhaupt und das ist ja
ganz subversiv das ist ja eine ganz
andere form der dass das macht
aufbrechen beispiel vattenfall pink
inszenierte 2015 eine pressekonferenz im
foyer des energieunternehmens und
verkündete eine radikale kehrtwende
vattenfall werde in zukunft nicht mehr
mit kohle arbeiten ich bin sehr froh
heute die nachricht verkünden zu können
auf die sie lange gewartet haben wir
werden 100 prozent verantwortung für die
lage zu übernehmen das heißt 100 prozent
erneuerbare energien hundertprozentige
ausstieg aus der braunkohle 100% zukunft
für die lausitz alles erfunden dass
vattenfall management überrumpelt und
warum weil politische parolen beim wort
nimmt und visionen für eine bessere welt
formuliert die in politischen hick-hack
vertagt und verbessert werden
in der politik was wir beobachten ist ja
ganz oft ein routiniertes spiel von die
einen sagen dass die anderen sagen dass
das ist hat irgendwie und das kennt man
alles schon
es ist ermüdend und dazu sagen da
springe ich mal rein und frage was ist
denn als was wäre wenn
wie könnte denn die welt anders aussehen
und lassen wir uns doch einfach auf den
gedanken ein dass ein unternehmen etwas
tut einfach nur weil es moralisch
richtig ist einfach nur aus diesem grund
weil es gut ist und nicht weil es
profite und dies und jenes und sondern
einfach nur weil es das richtige ist
hängt legt sich auch mit den ganz
mächtigen an
in diesem moment arbeiten tausende im
schatten der geheimdienste
sie gründeten eine plattform für
ausstiegswillige geheimdienst
mitarbeitende schnüffelt rinnen und
spione
ein perfekt inszeniertes video ruft dazu
auf auszusteigen oder
geheimdienstaktionen öffentlich zu
machen
hotel ob trier wenn ihr aussteigen
wollte nimmt intel exit
bis mord access intelligence na das wäre
machen ist die ästhetik der dies oft
sage ich mal die herzen der symbolik zu
übernehmen also dass das werbeagentur
machen das gewohnt sind zu und wir
gewohnt sind zu sehen
genau das nehmen wir und diese
bildsprache koppeln sie mit inhalten aus
der aktuellen politischen debatte wie in
diesem film der dafür wirbt flüchtende
illegal nach deutschland zu bringen
am anfang war eine ziemlich mulmig ganz
legal ist hier nicht was wir hier machen
wir machen das irgendwie so wie unsere
eigentliche die moni ahlen
sehgewohnheiten sind also die sehr
manipulative werbung nutzen wir als
beispiel um dann da rein eine ganz
andere nachricht zu setzen und plötzlich
denn die leute irritiert und denken hoch
moment war das auto werbung oder vasen
aufruf zur in der europäischen
fluchthilfe und warum und wo stehe ich
denn eigentlich also das ist so das
spiel ja was durch irritation eben eher
gedanken an liegt in der geschichte gab
es schon öfter flucht helferinnen und
das war in den betreffenden staaten
illegal
doch das eigentliche urteil wird nicht
vor gericht sondern in den
geschichtsbüchern gesprochen
jon peters buch ist keine
anekdotensammlung einer provokanten
protestkultur
es bietet zwar tipps für kreativen
subversiven widerstand ist aber
gleichzeitig auch ein essay über die
fließenden grenzen zwischen kunst aktion
und politischem aktionismus
ich glaube diese verzweiflung die ist
gerade gibt bei vielen wie was können
wir denn überhaupt noch tun und da habe
ich für mich einen weg heraus gefunden
und den will ich teilen und ich glaube
also die die resonanzen auf das buch
waren bis jetzt auch wären noch einmal
sich lebendig fühlen will in zeiten in
denen man eigentlich vielleicht sich
sehr verängstigt fühlt nicht genau weiß
wie geht's weiter und herzlich lachen
will und dabei aber auch merken
ich kann etwas bewegen dafür ist dieses
buch da das war ihm dem aktivisten und
aktionskünstler jean peters der auch
gerne afd politikerinnen mit torten
attackiert und in der medialen
öffentlichkeit agiert noch wichtig zu
sagen denn nun verschwindet er das war
das letzte interview für die nächsten
drei monate
er geht nach lesbos zu den geflüchteten
um dort zu arbeiten zu helfen ganz
unspektakulär
[Musik]
ja selber anpacken und geflüchteten
menschen helfen das wollte auch die
schauspielerin karl schuler bekannt aus
schweizer tatort kommissarin die
pandemie allerdings hat das bisher
verhindert nun aber schöpft sie aus
ihren fähigkeiten aus filmschaffende und
engagiert sich für flüchtlinge in seenot
[Musik]
vom glücklichen leben hinein in die
flucht
in nur zweieinhalb minuten kondensiert
das video diese geschichte initiiert von
carol schuler wurde es von 30
befreundeten kulturschaffenden
mitgestaltet
über die sozialen medien rufen sie auch
zur unterstützung der privaten
rettungsorganisation xii
deren neues viertes schiff hier noch im
hafen ist aktuell auf kurs ins
mittelmeer und es tut not
auch wenn hier gerade so ein bisschen
das öffentliche leben entschleunigt ist
und auch hause gedrückt ist geht das
sterben im mittelmeer sozusagen weiter
da sind erst wieder vor zwei wochen 120
geflüchtete ertrunken und das hat nicht
mal mehr so richtig den weg in die
schlagzeilen gefunden
im laufenden jahr verloren sogar schon
über 500 menschen ihr leben im
mittelmeer mit der neuen herannahenden
flüchtlingswelle verschärft sich die
situation alleine anfangs dieser woche
sind über 2000 menschen in lampedusa
angekommen
doch zivile seenotrettung wie die von zé
ist nicht unumstritten
die unfreiwillige unterstützung von
schleppern steht im raum sowie die
missachtung der gesetze
das wohl bekannteste beispiel carola
rakete die trotz verbot in lampedusa an
liegt für sie ging die aktion ohne
schuldspruch aus doch neben carol
schuler mit ihrem video gesetzesbrüche
in kauf das machen die figur des videos
schafft die überfahrt
doch diese bleibt für sie nicht die
letzte herausforderung
was hier noch gespielt wird ist für
abertausende menschen bitterer ernst
wir sind zurück im stadtcasino basel
hier haben die musikerinnen und musiker
des orchesters soeben zum aller ersten
mal die noten für das neue stück
bekommen
die erste probe steht an für eine
uraufführung terra incognita also
[Musik]
fischer kritisierte die regensdorfer
hoch schätzt dass ich jetzt einen
entscheidenden moment zum ersten mal
nötig seien komplett unbekannter stücke
risthaus vorprogrammiert
ich hoffe das ist natürlich
ja es wird
ja es ist natürlich ein spezieller
moment ist interessant ist erst einmal
für das projekt erste proben sind erste
mal jetzt aus meiner durch andere
projekte gespielt aber das projekt
deshalb können wir jetzt erstmal
zusammen
peter k
aber das neue stück einzige was ich raus
jetzt kauft ja
jetzt ist jedoch bisher user können wenn
sie sich darum es dank das ist
motivation dafür
das ist hier so das klassische konzert
auf das anders bekommen hat und mir
schwebte bevor das die trotzdem eines
persönlichen der bis unverwechselbares
bezugnahme das europäische projekt
gemacht
eine aktuelle zeitdruck und dass man
etwas riskiert das bei mir eben die ganz
verschieden
nach einem sehr steil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer beim neuen orchester in basel hat
man wirklich keine angst vor großen
vorhaben nichts weniger aus welten
verbinden ist das ziel das jedenfalls
der titel der aktuellen saison sie
werden es gleich sehen mit der welten
verbinden komponisten sind heute so jung
den laptop auf den knien und den großen
visionen zugetan
david lichtsteiner ist zu gast beim
volksmusik ensemble tritonus bei einer
probe in winterthur
also wenn ich dafür liege jetzt am
schluss habe ich es bis sie bedanke das
konzept wirklich offiziell sich alles
ist so überlagert dass es besser wird
und er vom orchester überdeckt werden
und minirock dem zwang ist eigentlich so
wichtig ich schätze dass ich zwei
instrument aus drei und sagt für die
idee dass diese gerade
[Musik]
helvetische volksmusik vor 1800 soll
david lichtsteiner nun mit klängen aus
dem nordosten indiens kombinieren diese
eigentümliche melodien hat er erstmals
in einer radioreportage von sf2 kultur
gehört im auftrag des orchesters besucht
er das kleine bergdorf kontron und
findet dort die außergewöhnlichen ruf
laute das dynamikum grundsätzlich
braucht wenn man private also weiter mit
aufmerksamkeit vor ihrem bett sowie
mehrere zelte als würde diese konvention
armen zurief melodie also die meisten
fans meter wo die hamas rief komponieren
mit dem ziel war die schwangerschaft und
die sportlichsten es denn wenn könig der
welt sind wenn es die oide arm und wie
gti und singet mellert jede zu es ist
für ihn etwas steht jetzt jemand lieber
nicht jetzt irgendwie passt sowie zudem
kennt das dass der name steinfeld einer
frauen ja auch mein vater ihres viert
geborene kind der sogenannten
[Musik]
indien meets appenzell david
lichtsteiner tüftelt zusammen mit boris
klauser an der musikalischen müll aus
[Musik]
dem orbit logo für und hirten lieder
sind seine passion musikforscher klauser
hat schon 1985 sein ensemble für alte
volksmusik mit gegründet
gewitter dass man zurückzieht um so
einfach sind sich die volksmusik vor
verschiedene länder oder sogar kulturen
oder sogar die ganze welt vor dem heiz
mit überhaupt nicht da herrscht und dass
das die eso einlass sind da gesehen ich
immer wieder bei meiner frau stecke ich
finde es geht noch ein mieter die
parallele wo aber muss ich auch für
richtig dass sie innerhalb von der
topographie entstanden ist die musik
also mehrheit deutsche zählbares mit
bios einfach dateien fotos musik in
europa entstanden sind um es ins in die
wittenberger oper und das führt dazu
dass man musik macht die höhere frequenz
valley den bergen aber die höchstgrenze
sicherheit komplett verteilt vorher
zurück wie die distanzen können sich gut
wenn man hilft also wenn ich irgendwo
oder darunter versuches 1 markus wenn
wir das in den club zum beispiel
übrigens lichtsteiners musikalische
reise ist von antonin dvorak inspiriert
der tschechische komponist reiste einst
in die ferne um neue melodien zu finden
indien appenzell und chuck ob dieses
welten verbinden klappt wir sind
gespannt
[Musik]
direkt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir noch mit dem dirigenten
komponisten david lichtsteiner die
äußere hat es das nach großem chaos denn
die allererste grob wie es gehen auch
also zum teil ist er intensiv raus so
ist witzig mal mein gestriger sie noch
ausdehnen und die zum teil klar ist
einfach noch aus sie werden in die alle
im gleichen boot sehen so verrückt ist
alles da machst aber das muss so sieht
das sind die rockband oder wer stoppt
das ist normal in dem fall schon die not
ist ein quasi trug früchte auf den
pulten betont einbuße akklimatisation
pause bis der entwicklungsprozess den
eingang und und die schönheit erst
ersichtlich wird ihr wandel bis großes
mit dem mit dem werke wandels der walter
zusammen kommen sie auf einem roller
oder selters jetzt noch mehr
zusammenwachsen den nächsten tagen buche
ich glaube es ist beides mit gewinnen es
gibt es im moment was wirklich so forsch
ging es ganz kurzen moment innehält
sowie die imitation ein ungewolltes und
da aber insgesamt hoffe ich schon ruft
das muss die leute sozial schwache sind
unsignierten wie es genannt oder aber
nicht nur das nachts habe und dass ich
wieder voller hoffnung also nicht nur
fremd sondern eher stunde nicht so
schmälzger ganz genetische auch die
zahlen und und ihn dir so habe es dort
sagt irgendwo unterwegs sehen wir das
ist wirklich vieles andere ist nicht
vorstellen was gibt es dann noch zu
jetzt werde die region bis zur u4 ich
will also einerseits dass man richtig
gut auch in die welt dass man muss
schauen wie rohdiamanten schliefer dass
sie einzelne diamant zum lüfter mit und
am schluss setzt vielleicht im idealfall
so sie wären eine reise machen
verschiedene war bekannt erklärt und
wenn er denn wieder zurückkommt von
reise ob man einer das gewohnte anders
und erfrischende blick der finde ich
toll und das ist eigener stil wenn uns
das auch unschöne ohr für ihre wünsche
mir und wann sie ist von der hauswand
mit
das konzert wird übertreibt radio sf2
kultur 27 stunden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja die konzerthäuser dürfen wieder die
kinos auch und diese woche geht eine
einheimische filmperlen stark das
mädchen und die spinne ist das neueste
werk der brüder silbern und ramon sicher
die beiden haben bei der berlinale einen
regie preis abgeräumt
wir haben die zwillingsbrüder in aarberg
getroffen dort wo sie einst aufgebrochen
sind die filmwelt zu erobern
direkt über der aare beginnt unsere
kleine reise mit den zürcher zwillingen
die vorhut 38 jahren hier im seeländer
städtchen am berg das licht der welt
erblicken
ramon links knapp 20 minuten vor seinem
bruder silva mit dem er schon früh die
liebe zum film entdeckte direkt an
dieser gut befahrenen hauptstraße in
diesem unscheinbaren häuschen dem kino
reihe bereits in der primarschule bei
den cinephilen brüdern klar wir wollen
gemeinsam filmemacher werden künftig
also kritik
[Musik]
die leidenschaft fürs kino durch strömt
ihr werk bis heute ist förmlich in jeder
pore ihrer filme zu riechen du stinkst
[Musik]
wir montieren duft verschob man hat sich
für die brüder dagegen der
lebensmittelpunkt heute wohnen die
aarberger primär in berlin sie stärker
voneinander abzugrenzen begannen sie
aber schon während ihrer berner
studienzeit in dem die zwillinge
individuelle stärken entwickelten
während silvan sein konzeptuelles denken
schärfte folgt der ramon seine musischen
veranlagung gnadenloser philosophie
studieren kunst studiert hat sowie die
trennung zwischen eher theoretischer um
er künstlerisch hauptsächlich echte
silberproduzent personal creative
producer produzent los
die hauptsache ist genau genau auf ihre
aufgabe machen wieder zusammen also aber
nach der schau stoff für die sache wie
für kreative entschädigung erfahrungen
machen wir in einem zimmer in ihrem
ersten szenischen höhenflug dritten die
zwei senkrechtstarter zusammen in berlin
zum tiefstpreis von 15000 franken mit
das merkwürdige kätzchen schlossen die
beiden 2013 ihr zusatzstudium im fach
film ab der beginn einer mehrfach
preisgekrönten festival karriere
den zweiten leinwand sonderling das
mädchen und die spinne konnten ramon und
silvan zürcher unter ganz anderen
bedingungen inszenieren im heimatkanton
bern mit schweizer fördergeldern
obwohl die handlung auch diesmal in
berlin spielt drehte das regie duo
seinen aktuellen kinofilm im studio auf
dem umfunktionierten areal der gurten
brauerei ganz bestimmtes niveau drum
hier mit den einfach weniger hier
nachholen
alles von grund auf neu zu entwerfen
kostete die brüder einerseits viel
energie entsprach andererseits aber auch
ihrem ausgeprägten gestaltungswillen der
bereits im drehbuch steckte die ein
blick zurück
es ist ein bis zwei schöne freundschaft
oder liebe geschäfts und hier immer von
der wohnbau also honig war die junge
frau haare ziehen und zwar nicht wegen
obwohl die zweite druck bleibt
hoffentlich hält es mit ihr aus diesem
loch bis zu verwächst hektisch später
erst sich aus nach dem triumph auf der
berlinale startet das mädchen und die
spinne in diesen tagen regulär in
unseren lichtspielhäusern mit all seinen
politischen unregelmäßigkeiten die der
film selbstreflexiv aufgreift
in form eines korrupten pdf alle
buchstaben und linien waren wirklich
einander gewürfelt das war schön die
chaotische angeordneten zeichen die
buchstaben die keine wörter mehr
gebildet haben
dann habe ich es geschlossen und wieder
geöffnet und plötzlich war alles wieder
normal
die buchstaben waren wieder wörter und
die dinge wieder der grundriss ich hab's
daraufhin immer wieder geschlossen und
geöffnet und gehofft dass es sich
wiederholt
aber es hat sich nicht wiederholt kein
einziges mal die faszination von mara
zudem zerstörte schossen gebete haft
oder anarchistische ist ausdruck zum
ende vor dem brüchiger aber auch jene
sehnsucht vor dass sachen nicht mit dem
pc sondern dass sie plötzlich überrascht
will auch wir lassen uns gerne weiter
vom erfrischend unkonventionellen kino
der gebrüder zürcher überraschen
egal wohin die reise der grenzgänger
letztlich geht was hat berlin gut baden
zähler und bio sie fürchtete sie unsere
ideale möglichkeit wird sie dann zu
sprechen und handeln so viel sei
verraten
der nächste film soll eine schweizerisch
deutsche koproduktion werden und der
spatz im kamin heißen ja wir wollen das
heimische kino schaffen unterstützen und
verlosen 10 x 2 tickets für das aktuelle
programm versuchen sie ihr glück und
schreiben sie uns eine mail
unter kulturplatz s11 punkt ch mit dem
vermerk back to cinema einsendeschluss
ist der 19
genießen wir doch die aktuelle
kulturwoche jetzt wo wir wieder dürfen
ins kino ins theater ins konzert wer
hier was auch nur für 50 glücklicher
immerhin geht nächste woche da geht es
bei uns um trübger punks wie aus kleinen
digitalen grafiken millionenschwere
kunstwerke und gleich jetzt geht es
weiter hier auf sf1 mit der serie die
wege des herrn kommen sie gut durch die
woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur
swisslos
[Musik]